♪ ♪
>> Ben: TIME NOW FOR A "SEEN
AND UNSEEN" WHERE WE EXPOSE THE
BIG CULTURAL STORIES OF THE DAY.
AND FOR THAT WE TURN TO FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR RAYMOND ARROYO.
RAYMOND, JILL BIDEN HAD A
MEETING WITH THE PRESIDENT OF
ISRAEL.
HOW DID THAT GO?
>> AS EXPECTED.
I DON'T WANT TO PREJUDICE THIS
BUT WHEN IT IS OVER, YOU TELL ME
HOW YOU FEEL ABOUT THOSE
AIR STRIKES IN SYRIA OVER THE
WEEKEND.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> AND -- I DIRECTED LAST WEEK'S
AIR STRIKES TARGETING SITE --
FOR RESPONSIBLE FOR E --
I ALSO WANT TO BE CLEAR AS I
SAID MY TEAM AND I ARE WORKING
CLOSELY WITH THE ISRAELI
GOVERNMENT THAT TOOK OFFICE
EARLIER THIS MONTH.
>> POOR SOUL.
IT WOULD'VE BEEN BETTER TO HAVE
THE DEFENSE SECRETARY OR SOMEONE
ELSE READ THE STOP.
CLEARLY HAVING SOME DIFFICULTY
SPIRIT IT ACTUALLY MAKES YOU
WORRY ABOUT WHO IS RUNNING THE
SHOW HERE.
THEN THERE IS THAT GESTURE IN
THE MEDIA BARELY COVERED THIS
EVENT.
THERE IS THIS GESTURE WE HAVE
SEEN BEFORE WHERE BIDEN RINGS
HIS HANDS.
THAT'S CALLED PERSEVERATION
WHERE PEOPLE REPEAT WHEN THEY
ARE IN DECLINE.
GESTURES OR PHRASES.
I'M NOT HERE TO DIAGNOSE HIM,
BUT THIS IS DEEPLY TROUBLING,
AND IT IS GETTING WORSE.
NOW HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT THOSE
SYRIAN AIR STRIKES?
SEE YOU AND YOUR TELLING ME THAT
IN ADDITION TO PROBABLY BEING
ILLEGAL BY ANY MEASURE, THOSE
ALSO MIGHT HAVE JUST BEEN THINGS
THAT JUST GOT GOING AROUND IN
CERTAIN AREAS.
IT HAD TO TELL YOU, THAT DOES
NOT MAKE ME FEEL GOOD WHATEVER
IT WOULD SAY BETTER.
>> IT'S HEARTBREAKING.
THERE'S A PART OF IT THAT IS
HEARTBREAKING.
KIM JONG UN'S WEIGHT LOSS GOT
MORE COVERAGE IN THE MEDIA THAN
THIS DATE, AND THIS IS FAR MORE
GRAVE AND IMPORTANCE.
SPEAKING OF INAPPROPRIATE
GESTURES, AMERICAN HAMMER
THROWER BRONZE MEDALIST STAGED
HER OWN PROTEST AGAINST THE FLAG
AND THE NATIONAL ANTHEM ON
SATURDAY PAIRED WHEN THE FLAG
WAS UNFURLED, SHE TURNED AWAY AT
PART HER HANDS ON HER HIPS AND
HIPS AND ROLLED HER EYES THREW
HER ACTIVIST ATHLETE SHIRT OVER
HER HEAD.
>> Ben: SHE SAID I FEEL LIKE
IT WAS A SET UP AND THEY DID ON
PURPOSE.
I WAS PASSED, TO BE HONEST.
RAYMOND, HOW IS IT A SET UP TO
HEAR THE NATIONAL ANTHEM AFTER
AN OLYMPIC EVENT?
HAD SHE NOT SEEING WHAT THEY
TYPICALLY DO?
>> THIS IS A HOLD POINTS.
NOW THE WHOLE COUNTRY'S PAST AND
NOT JUST HER.
WHEN YOU MAKE A CONTRACT, YOU
MAKE GOOD ON THAT CONTRACT.
YOU FOLLOW THROUGH.
THIS WOMAN HAS MANY CONTRACT
COULD.
SHE WANTS TO REPRESENT THE
UNITED STATES IN THE OLYMPICS.
THIS IS HER CHILD.
AND WHEN SHE GETS THERE, SHE
DISPARAGES AND PROTESTS AGAINST
THE COUNTRY.
IT'S JUST NOT THE RIGHT VENUE
FOR THIS.
A PROFESSIONAL ATHLETES WANT TO
DO THAT, THAT'S ONE THING.
THIS IS ENTIRELY DIFFERENT.
>> Ben: YOU ARE REPRESENTING
THE FLAG OBVIOUSLY.
THE WHITE HOUSE DEFENDED GLENN
BERRY TODAY.
>> PART OF THAT IN OUR COUNTRY
MEANS RECOGNIZING THERE MOMENTS
WHERE WE AS A COUNTRY HAVE NOT
LIVED UP TO OUR HIGHEST IDEALS
AND A MEANS RESPECTING THE OF
PEOPLE GRANTING IN THE
CONSTITUTION TO PEACEFULLY
PROTEST.
>> THEY ARE NOT HERE TO PROTEST,
THEY ARE HERE TO PERFORM.
YOU KNOW?
REMEMBER THE GOODWILL GAMES.
TED TURNER HAD THE GOODWILL
GAMES?
WE SHOULD HAVE THE PROTEST GAMES
AND THEY CAN HAVE THE HUNDRED
YARD COPPER CHASE.
THE LONG DISTANCE MOLOTOV TOSS.
WE CAN DO THOSE THINGS THEY ARE.
BUT THESE OLYMPIC TRIALS, IS NOT
THE PLACE FOR PROTESTS.
>> Ben: I JUST THINK THAT WHEN
IT COMES TO PERFORMANCES LIKE
THIS, IT IS OBVIOUSLY MEANT TO
TAKE AWAY FROM THE FACT THAT SHE
CAME IN THIRD AND TO --
MAKE THAT APPEAL.
YOU FORGET THE FACT THAT
COLIN KAEPERNICK RANKED 34TH OUT
OF 32 QUARTERBACKS FEARED THAT
HE GOT BENCHED.
JUST THE SORT OF THING THAT GOES
AWAY WHEN YOU PERFORM IN THIS
MANNER.
>> HAVE TO GET ATTENTION
SOMEHOW.
THIS IS HOW THEY DO IT.
FINALLY, THE CEO AND PRESIDENT
OF THE MAKE-A-WISH FOUNDATION
MADE AN ALARMING STATEMENT ABOUT
THEIR POST-PANDEMIC WHICH IS
LATE LAST WEEK AND IT'S REALLY
DISTURBING.
>> ALL PARTICIPANTS WILL NEED TO
BE TWO WEEKS PASS COMPLETION OF
EITHER A WINDOWS OR TWO DOSE
VACCINE.
>> THE VACCINE IS ONLY APPROVED
FOR CHILDREN OVER 12 YEARS OLD.
THESE ARE TERMINALLY ILL
CHILDREN WHO IN SOME CASES
CANNOT TAKE THE COVID VACCINE.
29 THEM THEIR WISH AS THEY FACE
ETERNITY IS NOT ONLY CRUEL, IT'S
FRANKLY ABSURD AND A CUTS
AGAINST THE ENTIRE REASON FOR
THIS FOUNDATION.
>> Ben: FOUNDATION IS NOW
CLARIFYING THEIR STANCE A WE
RESPECT EVERYONE'S FREEDOM OF
CHOICE.
MAKE-A-WISH WILL CONTINUE TO
MAKE WISH THEM --
NOT REQUIRE ANYONE TO GET
VACCINATED TO RECEIVE A WISH.
I'M GLAD THAT THEY RECONSIDER,
BUT WHOEVER HAD THIS IDEA IN THE
FIRST PLACE NEEDS TO REALLY GET
THEIR HEAD CHECKED.
>> BUT THAT STATEMENT IS A BIT
DECEIVING BECAUSE WHEN YOU READ
DEEPER YOU REALIZE THEY ARE
SAYING EVERYONE WILL BE
CONSIDERED TO RECEIVE A WISH.
HOWEVER, IF YOU ARE NOT
VACCINATED, THERE WILL BE NO
FLIGHTS, THERE WILL BE NO LARGE
GATHERINGS FOR YOU.
THAT IS CRUEL.
SINCE MOST OF THESE KIDS WANT TO
GO TO DISNEY WORLD, THAT IS OFF
THE TABLE FOR THEM.
THEY CAN ONLY DO A LOCAL WISH
FULFILLMENT.
I'M SORRY.
THESE BABIES COME IN THESE
FAMILIES ARE TRAUMATIZED.
THEY KNOW WHAT YOUR RISK IS
EVERY DAY OF THEIR LIVES.
YOU LET THEM EMBRACE AND YOU LET
THESE KIDS AND THESE FAMILIES
ENJOY THEIR TIME TOGETHER.
THAT'S WHY THIS PLACE EXISTS.
AND I HOPE MAKE-A-WISH, WHO HAS
DONE GREAT WORK IN THE PAS